this right here is the graph of y is
equal to X to the third over six plus
one over two x and what I want to do in
this video is figure out the arc length
along this curve between x equals one
and x equals two and so we've already
highlighted that in this purplish color
so I encourage you to pause this video
and try it out on your own and I'll give
you one hint
assuming that you apply the arc length
formula correctly it'll just be a little
bit of power algebra that you'll have to
do to actually find the arc length so
I'm assuming you've had a go at it let's
work through it together so a few videos
ago we got a justification for the
formula of arc length we got arc length
arc length is equal to the integral from
the lower boundary in X to the upper
boundary in X and this is the arc length
if we're dealing in terms of X we could
actually deal in terms of other
variables and so it's going to be 1 plus
f prime of x squared DX so for this
particular f of X we just need to figure
out what f prime of X is we need to
square it we need to add 1 to it and
then we have to take the square root of
that so let's do all of that
step-by-step so what is f prime of X I'm
going to be let's see X to the third
derivative of that is 3x squared so 3x
squared 3 over 6 so it's going to be x
squared over 2 and then this is 1/2 X to
the negative 1 is one way to think about
it and so that's going to be negative
1/2 X to the negative 2 negative 1/2 X
to the negative 2 power now what is f
prime of x squared so it's going to be
actually let's just write out what is 1
plus F prime of x squared so it's going
to be 1 1 plus F prime of X F prime of x
squared is going to be equal to it's
going to be 1 plus this
squared and so let's see this term right
here squared is going to be X to the
fourth over four so it's going to be X
to the fourth over four now the product
of these times two is going to get us
negative CX squared times X to the
negative two is just going to be one and
so it's just going to be negative one
half right I just took the product of
these two and then multiply that by two
yep it's going to just be negative one
half and then this term right over here
squared is going to be positive one
fourth X to the negative four one fourth
X to the negative four and let's see we
have a 1 and a minus 1/2 so we can
simplify that a little bit this is going
to be equal to X to the fourth over 4 1
minus 1/2 is plus 1/2 plus 1/4 plus 1/4
X to the negative 4 power let me make
that a little bit clearer X to the
negative 4 power so this just seems a
little bit strange and we're going to
take a square root of it but maybe we
can set this up so that it's a a product
of perfect squares because it does look
you know X to the fourth and let's see
if we can write this in a way that we
would recognize how to factor it a
little bit better so let's factor out a
1/4 X to the negative fourth power so
this is going to be equal to 1/4 X to
the negative 4 times so see I factored
that out so if you factor 1/4 X to the
negative fourth out of this first term
and I could color-code them a little bit
this first term when you factor this out
is going to be X to the 8th power now
this term right over here if I factored
out a 1/4 it's going to be equal to 2 X
to the fourth so this term right over
here once again this is the powering
through the algebra part so plus 2x to
the fourth and then this one is pretty
straightforward this is just going to be
equal to 1
so plus one plus one and now this is
looking interesting because this one
well this right over here we could
rewrite as 1/2 X to the negative two
squared this is equal to that same color
1/2 X to the negative 2 squared and then
this over here we could rewrite this as
X to the fourth plus let me write it
this way this is going to be X to the
fourth plus 1 squared right X to the
fourth times X to the fourth is X to the
8th 1 squared is 1 the product of them
times 2 is 2 X to the fourth so this
over here is the same thing as that and
so now if we wanted to take the square
root of both sides so if we wanted to
say the square root of 1 plus f prime of
x squared notice I'm just focusing on
the algebra so what we've done so far
this is 1 plus f prime of x squared now
we want to take the square root of that
so that's going to be the square root of
this and so that's going to be equal to
square root of this is let me just color
code it this is going to be 1/2 X to the
negative 2 power x times X to the fourth
plus 1 times X to the fourth plus 1 X to
the fourth plus 1 I do that right yep or
I could actually now that I did all of
this to put this in a form that I could
actually recognize now I can distribute
things back this is going to be equal to
this is going to be equal to 1/2 X to
the negative 2 times X to the fourth is
x squared 1/2 x squared plus 1/2 X to
the negative 2 and if we're going to
take if we're going to take the ax let
me rewrite this so that's 1 plus F prime
of x squared
but now let's take the definite integral
so I'm going to give myself some space
to write my DX so we're going to take
the definite integral in this case from
x equals 1 x equals 1 to x equals 2 so
it's the definite integral from x equals
1 to x equals 2 of this DX so it's going
to be the definite integral of this from
x equals 1 to x equals 2 DX and so this
is fairly straightforward the
antiderivative of 1 half x squared
that's going to be what that's going to
be 1 C X to the third and we divide by 3
so 1/2 divided by 3 is 1/6 1/6 X to the
third and then this is going to be we're
going to increment this is going to be X
to the negative 1 we're going to divide
by that so minus 1/2 X to the negative 1
power is that right did I do that you
have negative 1 when you take it yep
negative 2 and then this one yeah that
looks good and we're in the homestretch
we're going to evaluate it at 2 and at 1
and so we get when you evaluate it at 2
you get 2 to the third which is 8 over 6
minus 1/2 times 1/2 so this is minus 1/4
and when you evaluate it at 1 you're
going to have minus so we're going to
subtract evaluating it at 1 it's going
to be 1/6 minus 1/2 and now we just have
to evaluate these fractions so this is
going to be let's see this is if we
divide this is 4/3 4/3 minus 1/4 minus
1/6 and then we have plus 1/2 now see
the common denominator here would be 12
so this is be 4/3 over 12 is 16 over 12
all right and multiply the numerator
denominator by 4 minus 1/4 the same
thing as 3 over 12 this is minus 2 over
12 and then we have plus 6 over 12 and
so this is going to be equal to I think
we deserve a little at least
little mini drum roll right over here so
16 minus three is going to be 13 minus 2
is 11 plus 6 is 17 so there we have it
the length of that arc along this curve
between x equals 1 and x equals 2 that
length right over there is 17 17 12 and
we're done